we see these moments go viral like once
a month now this is another Wheel of
Fortune fail which are always fun so
we'll we'll watch this video but if you
if you're just listening to the audio
what you should know is that this puzzle
is already solved except for one letter
and the letter the answer is fresh
tropical fruit
all the letters are there except for the
s in fresh
and here's what happens
yes there is an age
uh solve it or spin it or but do
something quickly okay
okay what letter for you I'll go with a
G
no
uh Juliana it's your turn I'd like to
solve the puzzle yeah
fruit yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah you know when that happens and
you're sitting at home you're saying how
in the world connect but you know
sometimes it's a word that just doesn't
want to come into Focus for you it did
for you and in addition to that 650
we're sending you to the island of
Antigua Elizabeth
you know one of the Sounds in this there
are some sounds in life that are uh
always going to be horrifying and the
last sounds that you want to hear
uh like the sound of a crunching metal
when you're driving a car you know it's
just one of those sounds and if you've
been in a car actually you remember that
sound forever uh another of those sounds
is if you're on a game show and you hear
a gasp of horror from the audience
that's you never want to you never want
to hear that now you can hear the
audience go what
um although I do have to say you know I
do love frag tropical fruit I go all the
time to the grocery store and I say Hey
where's your frag fruit at
but this is why here's the point I want
to make about this it is it's important
but it's not important at all but still
uh I think the internet age
makes it not worth it to go on Wheel of
Fortune and I don't I don't say this to
just wait look I'm a fan of Wheel of
Fortune in Jeopardy
um like anybody else but it's it's just
it's I would never go on these shows
anymore and I say that as someone who
look I watch Jeopardy and I will kill
that show I I will absolutely kill it
when I'm sitting there in uh my best
games on Jeopardy are when I'm totally
alone in the living room and no one is
there to hear me answering the questions
correctly
um and then I'll have to go tell my wife
about it and she won't care at all but
and I I've thought to myself and maybe I
should go and but it's just it's
not worth it because if you have a brain
fart moment okay you have a moment where
just like you have a total lapse and you
draw a blank and you you know you a
moment like that will now live in infamy
forever you it will be it will follow
you so that this poor woman for the rest
of her life she's gonna have that moment
so that's what you risk
that's the risk the risk is that you
have a terribly stupid moment and it
haunts you forever because of the
internet
um that's the risk
that's the worst case scenario what's
best case scenario best case scenario is
that you win you know twelve thousand
dollars and a trip to Cancun or
something
it's not bad to win that but I don't
know if it's worth the risk
that's the best
that'll do it for this uh portion of the
shows move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet you can become a
member by using Code wallshit checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you over there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]